quand une personne est kidnappée
chaque seconde compte
les policiers qui enquêtent sur ces
affaires savent bien que si les victimes
ne sont pas retrouvés dans les 48 heures
on les retrouvera peut-être jamais ouais
dix mois ce qui s'est passé enfin je
veux dire elle est avec qui elle parlait
avec quelqu'un dehors toutes ces filles
que tu vois ici on n'a jamais retrouvé
un seul corps qu'est-ce qu'on a un pass
corp à domicile mike
ou est-ce que tu étais si j'étais chez
moi qui vis clarté c'est pas possible et
suppôts cours au t1 et lorsqu'on l'a pas
fait cette fille tu le reconnais
c'est quoi où est bon mais c'est quand
même tant pis
jacky si je sais que j'ai la réponse est
sûr pourquoi je ne fais rien
une autre fille a été justement envie
tu crois que c'est
c'est pour elle